this hello welcome to this press
conference following the 14th meeting of
the foreign ministers of asia-europe
meeting
azzam higher presentative vice president
at bow hell will present you the outcome
of the meeting and then the Minister of
Foreign Affairs of Singapore as
coordinator for ASEAN will also say a
few words and we will then take your
questions
hi representative please thank to all of
you who would like to sign the
government of Spain on behalf of the
European Union for hosting in this
beautiful palace that belongs to the
national heritage national Spanish
heritage we also want to thank his
Majesty the King for allowing us to use
this beautiful place and for the
excellent job on organizing this
important ministerial meeting that has
been fruitful and I hope opened the door
for a future cooperation to repeat newly
attaches a great importance to its
partnership with Asia we have a scale up
our cooperation in and with ASEAN
partners in recent years developing a
stronger political ties and a deeper
security engagement that so many Asian
partners came to Madrid today show us
the partnership is also important for
them and at a time of many changes in
the international landscape we need each
other and we need to work more closely
together today more than ever is my
first meeting my first international
conference as High Representative for
security and foreign policy of the
European Union and I am glad to do it
here with a same which is a unique
platform for European energy partners
for dialogue and engage it in common
challenges just think about that we
together represent fifty five percent of
global trade sixty percent of global
population 65 percent of global GDP
two-thirds of the world
revenue is being generated in our
countries these are very impressive
numbers and show that we together should
be able to make a global difference
our theme the theme with choose for the
conference Asia in Europe together for
an effective multilateralism shows very
well this well I been drafting together
with all the colleagues and let's say
German statement but it has been agreed
I can say by all of us although
everybody would have liked to say things
in a different way in one point or
another but I think that this statement
is a good balance of our work we have
been talking about many subjects and why
not and especially for sure about
climate change today
Spain is an important day also because
we have been hosting the last conference
of climate change and we are very much
aware that sustainability we have been
saying during our lunch needs to have
taken into consideration the three
dimension environmental dimension
socio-political dimension connectivity
has played a very important role in our
work connectivity between Europe and
Asia is at the same time threat and an
opportunity is bringing about countries
people and societies it has very
concrete aspects transport networks
digital connections but more important
than all that is also about people
people-to-people contacts through
location and exchanges common knowledge
research programs tourism whatever
brings human being together this is at
the end our endeavor this is at the end
of a zone that of this meeting will meet
in one year from now in Cambodia my last
words has to be to thank all the people
engaged in organizing this conference
you cannot believe how many people has
to work in order to make it possible
from the kitchen to the transportation
from translators to the people who
strive to reach a common agreement on a
text to all of them from the most humble
activity to the highest intellectual
level of all people engage thank you
very much nice back travel home thank
you
Thank You Joseph and I suppose I should
start by congratulating you on your new
appointment in the EU and with that we
are honored that one of your first tasks
was to chair this meeting as I have said
earlier sessions ASM has grown by leaps
and bounds in the last 23 years started
off with around 26 members we're now at
53 and as you have just outlined just
now more than 60% the global population
of trade and of GDP is accounted for by
Asia and by Europe I would also make the
point that now even more than before the
reason that of ASM is even more salient
this is a time of great change a time
and as a pushback against globalization
against free trade against economic
integration there is a profound anxiety
in the middle class of many societies
all over the world and we need to double
down on free trade on integration
on investments on economic
interdependence and the fact that the EU
and I speak now on behalf of my Asian
colleagues have been able to make a
statement and to converge our minds on
the cause of free trade is worth
highlighting in the case of a tiny
city-state like Singapore we are
gratified that the EU Singapore free
trade agreement came into force on the
21st of November this in fact just last
month and we are also looking forward
that this is just the first step of what
will hopefully ultimately be a free
trade agreement between the EU and ASEAN
if you look at this historically the
European Union in my opinion is the most
successful regional organization in the
world Europe a continent which generated
two world wars in the last century
because of the EU has now made war
unthinkable in Western Europe no matter
what travails you go through I think
every Europe European should be grateful
and should count your blessings
that you have secured the peace but
having said that I've also outlined in
my previous intervention that in fact
Europe has a head start in Asia the
history when of course history sometimes
has both positive and negative aspects
but that legacy of goodwill that
reservoir of trust culture and
technology is there waiting to be
harvested and we know that in the last
couple of decades and especially the
last four decades Asia has been the
locus of tremendous economic growth and
if you look within South East Asia alone
we have six hundred and forty million
people
the majority of whom are below the age
of 35 there's a demographic and
technological dividend waiting to be
harvested and my point is that as a
longtime partner that you is welcome to
participate in this growth story so the
fact that we were able to have an
excellent meeting frank candid exchange
of minds and there we reaffirmed our
belief in free trade on cooperating on
issues like cyber security climate
change all this org as well for the
future so again let me thank you and
thank Spain and thank all the staff who
have been working furiously behind the
scenes to create such a seamless and
successful meeting Thank You Joseph
congratulations
[Applause]
[Applause]
I will now open the floor for your
question please introduce yourself and
the media you're working for
good afternoon I work for Spanish news
agency robot press sorry for my voice
because I have a bad cold today
I would like to ask you first if there
was any talk about the situation in Hong
Kong in the meeting secondly you spoke
the of a possibility of a free trade
agreement between Europe and Asia I
thought I understood that do you see the
the possibility of a trade agreement
between the all the countries in SM or
what I'm talking about here and lastly
if I may ask a question to the High
Representative concerning the new
commission of which you are part I was
wondering what a plan teleprompting
casiano mucho eco Parliament a kiria
preguntar lay sobre UN possible proyecto
de la nueva misión europea de la que se
habla de en algún momento o hemos visto
en bruselas comme un tribunal Belga abou
el Toa retrace our Munna Bista judicial
respect ona persona req Lamar opponent
res personas req lamanna's por una orden
en Espana new estará preguntar lazy la
no la comisión tienen trace us plans
reformed our la orden negro pea de
detention e entrega a para intentar
evitar que en el futuro su sedan estas
cosas de dez confianza entre Estados
gracias
would you like to answer this oh well
maybe let me start off by dealing with
the question of trade and I will focus
first on Southeast Asia ASEAN is a
association with ten member states all
of us in Southeast Asia for us we
believe that free trade properly
negotiated and rigorously implemented is
an avenue to generate opportunities for
our people
so first within ASEAN itself we have an
economic community and we're trying to
create a single production zone a single
investment destination within the ten
countries of Southeast Asia beyond that
we have we meaning Ascend has free trade
agreements with six major partners the
major partners are India China Japan
South Korea Australia and New Zealand in
fact right now we have substantially
concluded an agreement which we call the
regional comprehensive economic
partnership this includes therefore the
16 countries that I have enumerated if
we succeed in finalizing this this will
be the world's biggest free trade
agreement in addition to this some of us
in Southeast Asia are also members of
the trans-pacific partnership in fact
the trans-pacific partnership started
off as a small an agreement amongst
three four small states Singapore Brunei
Chile and New Zealand later on the
bigger states got involved well I think
you all know the United States pulled
out of the TPP but nevertheless with
Japan's leadership
eleven of us managed to get together to
sign it we added two adjectives to it
come comprehensive and progressive
trans-pacific partnership and to our
surprise we've even been able to bring
that into force at the end of the
previous year now from Singapore's
perspective having settled a free trade
agreement with you we think the next
logical step is to consider a two region
Europe on one hand Southeast Asia on the
other hand this will not be easy it will
be difficult because of the sheer
numbers and diversity of the economy is
concerned but nevertheless if we can do
it this will be a statement of intent a
statement of reaffirmation of the
importance of free trade as a strategy
for economic development so that's what
we are looking forward to I'm not at all
saying this will be easy or that this
will happen quickly but I think this is
an ambitious goal worth going for now
having said that I also need to make
this point that I think in the past too
many people have assumed that free trade
on his own is an unadulterated good and
the truth is free trade has both winners
and losers and it is a responsibility of
every national negotiator to carefully
negotiate the terms so that there is a
net benefit for the citizens of that
country and equally important that there
must be domestic legislation and
domestic policy to provide sufficient
safety nets for those who might be at
least temporarily adversely affected by
free trade so this requires both foreign
and domestic policy to work in concert
but we believe that you is a worthy
partner for us work through these
difficult political challenges because
ultimately this is a question of
politics so it is an ambitious goal but
I'm gonna leave it in the hands of my
good friend Josef and we'll see where
this leads to don't know whether you
want to disagree or at them I'm not
disagreeing at all by the contrary I
thank for your enlightening and
inspiring words you should come more
often to Europe and explain these kind
of things because you do it very very
well much better than much of the
European politicians that's to need an
outsider to tell you what a good thing
you have that's true when people look at
you from outside they have a certain
perspective and you are very much right
trade trade everything in life the good
side and not such a good side trade as
any human activity produces winners and
losers and even if the net balance is
positive we have to take into account
the losers and maybe we were not aware
that the number of losers were so big
and what's happening today in the world
in many countries is a little bit the
backlash of globalization the fact that
the losses of globalization and now are
in a pin number in order to make their
interests and their worries
very much in the political landscape
and this comes from Latin America to the
streets of Paris when any everywhere but
at the same time I think that we have to
continue opening our economies in order
to look for a global optimum I use this
opportunity to regret that the World
Trade Organization has become an
operational due to the lack of
cooperation of the United States that
has made that the judges are nothing
number enough in order to operate and I
think that a set of bilateral agreements
uncoordinated bilateral agreements
brings us to a suboptimal situation with
respect to what would be an overall
agreement this is almost mathematics
know a set of bilateral agreements not
taking into account what's happening
with the other all together it's Tsubaki
mo with respect to an overall agreement
that unhappily is far out of reach on
those days but Asia and Europe has a
common future to build we are
complementary and when you see how
important for our jobs the export to
China
how important is for you prosperity our
imports the investment all issues that
make us partners like it or not so we
have to continue working together
because the humankind will bury me very
much in balance with that the good
understanding between Europe and Asia
and about the other issue cerca de
l'autre question yo creo que también
aqui aqui therapy dajia explicar que lo
que se trata de una ley she owned no
entry gobierno z-- c no intrepid eres
judiciaries que no solos Minister of
Delhi interior de cada pious Rose Cape
Eden Extra Deck Sione's de su colega
Sina Carson los West's Tompa ystös que
le pedan a sus colleague azeotrope Isis
estamos construyendo un espacio
horrifico europeo supranational ESO no
se Vassar dara noche a la mañana por que
que creer common trust la confianza
muchas de manera que es del pi is a
attend a la petición de where del pay
his bail
combin see me ento tigre persona
requried arrest Avira el mismo trot okay
Vera recibido en el pasado y eso chokha
comas logic o con las practical school
Torre's pass Astoria's que cada Pais
tiene con los demás naturalmente se
puede mejor are sa DB mejor are y DB my
opinion a perm s cooperation
antara distancia Judi cialis de un país
de otro se puede rebus are Norden pues
Mira stead no soy un especially Stanny
desmet area fundamental como alto
representante pero sin si puede matteiru
no opinion posse creo que si Claro que
se puede agarrar se puede mejor are
sobre todo a traverse a metal is Mo's
que creen confianza Mutua enter los
padres UGC alleys un paseo tro crows
decibel messy entre ellos que alguien t
Runa do de la pregunta y las claire Eska
pero no hay cosas son de sunta nahi cod
autoridades Judi cialis de flan days
todavía no Antony Doe of en hacer caso
ordinary pea de una conocida tera case
le wreck lawmen delitos de sangre
Casey Gaston Doan verheek a tranquila
mente porque de los jueces no an
consider a dope or - no case a personas
Yahoo Dada en españa seersucker a
dentists de acción owes you a nose Davis
train our coke urine otras cosas para
todos se vasa en la necesidad de creer
los mismos mekinese Mo's que existe nel
interior deceased Emma Judy see al de
cada Pais
s Tripoli dos Annabelle blow pero en eso
estamos la tarea Sara larga
pero cualquiera que si an los accidentes
de recorrido creo que es bueno intent
are no volver atrás y que vole vamos a
la época en la que las s tradiciones
resolve e'en a traverse day
doctors personalities interest ministers
the interior the calipers this mucho
mejor the Harlow issue a man of the
respuestas is Kalos the order so la si
se para construir una spacio hoody see
an adorable file Kenya's from the
Spanish news agency FM a question for
high representative Laurel please after
the meeting you have you had the gesture
the evening with Chinese Foreign
Minister 1e and his reply to you do you
think that's in your new your current
position you can engage in an effective
way the Chinese government in issues
like democracy in Hong Kong or human
rights in Xinjiang without being
rejected as someone interfering in
China's internal affairs thank you well
when we talk about human rights you have
to do it with full respect the countries
in which we are with with whom we are
dealing with I have a strong really good
relation with the foreign affairs
minister of China since I met him when I
have years ago in New York I don't see
any inconvenience we have been talking
about the subjects you refer to and we
will continue doing it and the best
approach in order to express the big
concerns and we Europeans have about
human rights all over the world the
specific situation which country taking
into account the characteristic of each
one of them and with full respect it's
clear that when you deal with these
kinds of things
you are entering in domestic issues but
human rights is not a domestic issue
human rights is a universal issue
good afternoon my name is Nadia ChaCha
and I am here on behalf and well thanks
to the asia-europe foundation because
they have invited me to attend the 12th
version of the journalist seminar here
in Madrid
we were able to discuss the different
perspectives together and do capacity
building knowledge sharing for immediate
trust and sharing knowledge about how we
can combat this information and bringing
that together between our Asian and
European counterparts and sharing is not
just incredibly valuable and thanks to
them we were able to attend the press
briefing here today so thank you for
having us here my question is as follows
under your theme of inclusion I was
wondering whether or not you have
discussed or whether you will build on
the agenda the point of structured
dialogues that the youth presented
during the moderation presentation of
the points that they made in their chair
statement thank you
it's a question for me on what josy for
bother for I think it's for both of us
well first of all I'm glad that we had a
immortal youth dialogue I had the
opportunity to spend some time with the
three Singaporeans so obviously I ever
slightly biased perspective we believe
it's very important to get young people
involved because after all the young
people have the largest stake in the
future and when you talk to the young
people in particular those in Singapore
their number one concern is jobs meaning
where the new jobs being created what
skills do they need and are our
respective education systems providing
them with the necessary skills not for
yesterday's jobs but for tomorrow's jobs
further another concern for people who
are not so young is that we are now
living in an age and I think most of us
will have two or three or more jobs in
our lifetime and the old model where
University some all a technical school
is something you attended before you
started work
I think that's an industrial age model
and that will have to end and in fact in
Singapore we are looking at what we call
skills future which means you are taking
adults middle aged people or even people
who are not so young and giving them a
chance to learn pick up new skills so
that they're ready for the next job and
we are focused on providing the
educational infrastructure we focus on
empowering our unions because after all
your current employer is not necessarily
most interested in your next job but
your union will be because the union
wants to keep you as a member
for life beyond their it's also very
important for us to understand that
governments do not have all the answers
and if you talk about the industry
transformation is occurring in societies
in fact it is the businesses it is the
private sector that is closer to the
ground
closer to the challenges and knows
what's relevant was useful what to
pursue so it's very important for
governments to get the right model of
working relationship with the private
sector because we have to focus on
restructuring our economies so from my
perspective these are the the key issues
which young people are concerned with
jobs a sense of hope for the future and
then also equally important a sense of
participation and a sense of ownership
if we can provide these key elements to
our young people whether they are in
Europe or in Asia I think we'll have a
bright a very bright future ahead of us
well I think I'm continuing inviting you
to come to erode it's difficult to add
something to this very inspiring words
that's true we have been listening to
several young people in our plenary
meeting today and we will take into
account your contributions I think the
fact that some young people from Europe
and from Asia has been invited to come
to Madrid to participate at that meeting
shows a clear message about how these
Union projects into the future and my
co-president is very much right an
important thing for the new generations
is which place they are going to have
and productivity on the industrial on
the services economy that is coming and
is coming from Asia the new waves of
innovation are coming from Asia
if mr. what you know what the guy the
British who invented the steam machine
mister what had been a Chinese the war
would have been completely different but
he was a British and now the mr. what of
the future
they have a strong probability of not
being European but being from Asia the
new wave of innovation are coming from
Asia and this will alter the columbic
structure productivity and jobs that's
why we should be more together you know
that not to create a big divide as it
happened in the past revolution among
the ones who has the technology and
imposes their power to the others that
doesn't have this technology we have to
share the technological development in
order to create a more harmonious world
that they want that we inherited from
the first of all Industrial Revolution
era from the star media group from
Malaysia
yes mr. bean this is a question for you
recently there's been ongoing reports of
plastics or rubbish being dumped from
developed countries to developing
countries and as you speak on behalf of
Asian countries has this topic been
discussed and what kind of solutions are
you looking forward to it and of course
on the sidelines if there's anything any
kind of updates that you've spoken to
the Malaysian counterparts thank you
well the issue of pollution due to
plastics and micro plastics especially
into the marine environment was brought
up by several speakers at our at our
session so this is a clear and present
danger and I think all of us are acutely
aware of this I'm also aware that there
have been some cases of contaminated
plastics being transported to my
surprise across
large oceans to other countries where
they supposed to undergo recycling I
think it is important for us to realize
first there are international
conventions for dealing with the export
or import of hazardous materials and it
is important for all of us to comply
with those conventions the second point
is emphasize transparency and when we
detect something - to exchange
information with all the states in that
supply chain or in that budget extreme
and I can tell you from experience that
this indeed is happening the third point
is to make sure that the businesses are
held accountable for the outcome you
know I speak as a former Environment
Minister a lot of problems in the
environment occur because the
externalities that are imposed are
socialized on the rest of us and on the
environment and not on the people
privatizing the gains and we need to
work towards a world where every body
and every private corporation is held
accountable for the externalities that
are caused by their activities and this
can only be done if we work collaborate
across borders and that's why I still
believe in multilateralism I still
believe in international law I still
believe in healthy cooperation between
states that's the only way you can
resolve this problem well I am also a
former Environment Minister mrs. Merkel
also as a former Environment Minister I
completely agree with you
I think next meeting in Cambodia
multilateralism is good but sometime it
can be a little bit boring because when
you ask 53 people are on the table and
each one of you have three minutes
it takes long and in three minutes you
cannot cover everything and at the end
is some general statements without going
deeper into the subject you race maybe
you have to select three or four five
deep issues in order to concentrate on
that and one after the other
not everybody has to talk about
everything but we would have been more
productive today let's do a little bit
of criticism how to criticism we had
been focusing more on several issues
which are hot issues in order to deliver
some I wouldn't say agreement but a list
some common understanding of where the
problem are which could be the solution
because the humankind today is facing
more than ever the problem of
externalities prices don't send the good
economic signal because they don't take
into account effects which are as much
as important as the price itself and
today people are taking awareness of
that and this is going to be a big
revolution when the European Union we
decided last week that we will be carbon
neutral in 2050 we are opening the door
to a big geopolitical turmoil because
this is going to change the distribution
of wealth and power in the world and
it's creating once again losses and
winners and countries who today are very
rich maybe they will not be so rich
countries were very poor maybe do we
have an opportunity because they will be
able to produce things in order to build
batteries electric batteries that will
be the engines of the future so we are
opening the door to an unknown future we
will require a lot of cooperation this
is a magic work
we can solve the problems through
cooperation or through confrontation and
the SM is a good tool to go on the way
of cooperation thank you I don't see yes
please one last question of the young
man hello everyone my name is a kill a
convenient I come from India and I'm
also at my colleague mentioned as one of
the passive participant in journalist
seminar so I thank Asif and for the
Bingbing for bringing together young
media professional across from different
countries from both these continent my
question is I was going through the
chairs statement and I was also
listening to the various ministers
talking about the numerous geopolitical
issues in both the continent but I
didn't find anything I mean here is
mention of European Union here is
prominently mention of ASEAN but there
is no mention of Sark and I think Sark
the southeastern regional corporation
and I think here are the ministers from
India representatives from India
Pakistan and other South Asian countries
so my question is was there a concern
raised on the issue and is there any way
to go ahead because given the Asthma my
understanding I think the given the
fragile geopolitical situation in the
region I think operation body like Sark
is a you know need of the time you know
though you know more than I about it
well the first thing I want to say is
that ASM is not the United Nations this
is a voluntary
Sang's membership and obviously not all
members of Asia and Europe are
necessarily signed on to it yet although
as I said at 53 it's a good and healthy
number next point I would make is that
in fact India Pakistan Bangladesh was
represented and spoke and we had a house
how do I put it entertaining would not
be a fair description but we had a
lively we heard we heard a lively
exchange of views between India and
Pakistan and similarly between so there
was good participation and the issues
will hurt and I think you will agree it
was a very candid exchange so don't
worry the issues concerns were raised to
quote my colleague from Pakistan that's
all we have time for unless High
Representative okay thank you we
continue like this we are going to
convert this press conference in another
session of the meeting or the same so I
think it has been very instead
interesting questions thank you for
giving the opportunity of sharing point
of views I really appreciated your way
of dealing with the issue that worries
and it's a big pleasure to meet you I
hope do we continue every forward to
welcoming you in Asia I feel I will that
we have to engage deeply in Asia for
sure thank you the future of Europe
[Applause]